Donald Trump held a rally in Ohio on
Saturday night it was ostensibly for J.D
Vance who's the Republican Senate
candidate there running against Tim Ryan
this was the most cultish Trump rally I
have ever seen a new staple at the Trump
rallies is that when Donald Trump is
doing his kind of final build to his
make America great again make America
safe again they now play
I don't even know like like an esoteric
musical bed that almost seems fake it
almost seems like a parody this is the
one of the strangest moments I've ever
seen at any political rally ever
globally experts on Fascism and Cults
are pouring over this video like the
Zapruder film take a look at this
we are a nation that allowed Russia to
devastate a country Ukraine
killing hundreds of thousands of people
and it will only get worse and what you
can see there is the cult people holding
up a single finger now there's to it
there's a bunch of interpretations of
this one is there's this Q Anon thing
which is like uh I I forget exactly it's
like wwg1wga
and what the phrase means is where one
of us goes we will go together and so
the one that is being held could be the
one from that Q Anon thing another
interpretation is they're doing the Heil
Hitler but with a single finger to make
it less crazy looking I don't think that
that's what this is
it's insane but this is a very serious
cult it would never have happened with
me as your commander-in-chief
and for four long years it didn't happen
and China were Taiwan
[Music]
ized it's law enforcement against the
opposing political party
like never ever before
we've got a Federal Bureau of
Investigation that won't allow bad
election-changing facts to be presented
to the public
where Hunter Biden's laptop folks this
is the United States this is a former
president
was Russian disinformation when they
knew it wasn't
and a department of justice that refuses
to investigate egregious acts of voting
irregularities and fraud
and we have a president who is
cognitively impaired and in no condition
to lead our country which may end up
in World War III yeah somehow I don't
think so we're a nation that no longer
has a free press
has no fair press any longer fake news
is all you get and they are truly the
enemy of the people we are a nation
where free speech is no longer allowed
where crime is rampant like never before
where the economy has been collapsing
where more people died of covet in 2021
than in 2020 we are a nation that is
allowing Iran to build a massive nuclear
weapon and China to use the trillions of
dollars it has taken from all right
let's pause it here
like nothing I have ever seen before
truly and completely fascistic these are
sort of like
dictatorial wet dreams I mean this this
would make Fidel Castro blush quite
frankly
um later on a lot of other of the
typical things also happen during the
speech later on Donald Trump seemed to
forget where he was like where he was
giving the speech and he referred to it
as this location are you McKinley you
know he's a great president he was the
king of tariffs that's why I like him
because he said that we don't want other
foreign powers coming in here and
stealing our wealth
he was hailed from right here he came in
from this right this location
that's the best he was such an important
place he was from it was from right this
here where we are now
um Donald Trump still completely
scrambled on Ulysses S Grant continuing
to first of all it's weird how much
Trump refers to Ulysses S Grant and it's
also weird that he keeps calling him
Ulysses
for their Beloved Country Ohio is the
state that gave us
American Heroes icons and legends with
names like Neil Armstrong Annie Oakley
and the great General and President
Ulysses S Grant but there is Ulysses uh
still I mean you would think someone
would come up to him with tears in their
eyes and say sir it's Ulysses uh Donald
Trump uh bemoaned the claims about a
urine tape involving Trump saying it was
really tough to explain that one to
Melania in the phony steel dossier it
was all phony how'd you like to be me
and go home and explain that one to my
wife
darling it wasn't true I swear it wasn't
remember that one with the hookers from
Russia
darling I'd like to explain this to you
it was all phony it was all a phony made
up yep it was all fake and then lastly
it wasn't all fun and games there was a
moment where the crowd in in Ohio
was so bored that they were in complete
silence and at one point in this clip if
you're watching you'll see the camera
cut to the crowd they are they almost
look like statues and 100 would have
never happened should have never
happened but we gave now
80 billion dollars and Europe has given
six now Europe is a similar size when
all added up to the United States the
economy Europe if you add it all up and
they're in for a lot less money than us
and you know it's a sad thing because
they're in for less but they're affected
a lot more than we are yeah just an
electric environment there an electric
atmosphere so a deranged rally in Ohio
was supposedly in support of JD van and
at one point during the thing Trump
actually made fun of JD Vance it's all
backwards it was all completely uh
people's brains are turning to
mayonnaise at these rallies is what it
seems like and of course the attendees
weren't much better let's look at that
next
imagine this scenario you try logging
into your email account to see that your
password was changed a few hours ago
except you didn't do it and then you get
notifications of activity from your bank
and from your credit cards but you
didn't do any of it that is what
identity theft is like it can happen
very quickly and if you don't act fast
it can get worse we've dealt with this
at the David Pacman show you can find
videos about it and that's why I protect
myself now using Aura our sponsor Aura
is Identity Theft Protection fraud
monitoring password management and an
antivirus all in one easy to use app
Aura will monitor the dark web for your
emails passwords and Social Security
numbers and we'll send you alerts
quickly to your phone and email Aura
also gives you near real-time alerts on
suspicious credit inquiries like if
someone was opening a loan or a credit
card in your name and if you sign up at
aura.com Pacman you will get a free
two-week trial which you can use to see
if your login credentials have been
leaked online I would want to know that
right away use the link below